plus tôt, vous avez dit qu'il y a des
gens qui savent que vous allez pourquoi ai-je
le sentiment que ce n'est pas vrai mr.
gris votre prochaine réunion est dans la
conférence pour le conseil s'il vous plaît nous n'avons pas
fini ici oui monsieur non je suis à moi je peux y
aller c'est bon j'aimerais en savoir plus
sur vous il n'y a vraiment pas grand chose à
savoir sur moi vous avez dit que vous '  je suis une
majeure en anglais, dis-moi que c'était Charlotte brontë
Jane Austen ou Thomas Hardy qui
t'a fait tomber amoureux de la littérature
hardy
j'aurais deviné Jane Austen quels
sont tes plans après avoir obtenu ton diplôme
j'essaie juste de passer la finale en ce
moment et  puis et puis j'avais l'intention de
déménager ici à Seattle avec Kate, nous
offrons un excellent programme de stages, je
ne pense pas que je m'intégrerais ici, regardez-moi,
je suis